Sienna seems peaceful and in order when
viewed from the 100 meter bell tower
that rises high above the city and the
piazza del campo
once Sienna had many towers building one
was how a family demonstrated its power
in 14 19 after a political quarrel the
selling beini family was expelled from
the city its palazzo was confiscated and
made the seat of the first bank in the
world for 500 years the monte de paz
keybank contributed to Sienna's
affluence that ended in 2012 when the
bank ruined itself with an expensive
merger and risky financial derivatives
the bank's president had to resign the
public prosecutor is investigating the
bank's practices several former managers
are under house arrest mucho mas nadie
unfortunately we were the site of one of
Europe's biggest financial speculations
to the tune of 20 billion euros DD means
you lean toward Naveen Tamiya did a row
now this money is gone and we're sitting
on a huge mountain of debt photo sent an
amino to today Rizzo senators are you
know II the city of Siena is not only
hard hit it is impoverished Grameen tip
of it easy a painful blow for once rich
Siena through a foundation the city was
the bank's biggest shareholder hefty
dividends provided plenty of money and a
few fashion it after it started yet said
it was easy to walk across the piazza
del campo to ask the bank foundation for
money Monyetta roof money was always
forthcoming lots of it and fast with a
little chain pd no one had to think
about additional revenues for the city
or about reducing outlays and so siena
never had to learn to budget makeba de
vinter adulto the blogger and book
author rafa Elias carry calls the
alliance between politics and the bank
the system in the shadow of the bell
tower it always ruled the city he says
in accordance with principles all too
typical for italy as a whole
esta don't sistema de riccati everyone
extorted each other and scheme to get
the bank's money now is it a go for and
you avoided making enemies especially
within the Democratic Party that
governed here for generations article
that likes to present itself as a moral
authority en la porta siempre bonito
como qui non negative e con la persona
que comen dava ass carries blog has
repeatedly accused politicians and
bankers of mismanagement he says they
are to blame for the city's huge debt
Coney sword the heavy videla phone that
soon with all the money from the bank
foundation the city wouldn't have had to
take taxes and fees from its citizens
look I know Misha poly invasion we could
have lived tax-free deficit but the
money was spent prodigiously so and now
we have to pay off the debts with the
highest city taxes in all of Italy
natalia Sienna's hospital is one of the
best in central Italy and was run with
money from the bank now that money is
gone the renowned musical Academy faces
the same situation here the foundation
is no longer a sponsor except on the
poster the bank has stopped being a
patron in Siena
and it's the same in sports the
basketball team has been Italian
champion eight times now without its
banks sponsor it may lose its license
the situation is similar for the
football team the bank has cut off its
funds to sports fans in the old city are
frustrated
we thought our bank was solid and had no
problem spending these amounts but we've
learned a painful lesson city davao you
guys in this course in a bank you don't
know yet to eat Bambi they just want
support from the population and where do
you get it in Italy in the stadium when
the home team wins whether it's in
football or basketball team dainty bread
and circuses was a successful strategy
for bankers and politicians for a long
time as Sienna's sports fans now
self-critical II admit the effects of
the bank crisis are not over banks will
shed 5,000 jobs and 400 branch offices
throughout Italy and the debt remains to
be paid chrysalis buddy media rd media
Bank crash annihilated billions they
have to have gone somewhere they can't
just vanish into thin air melodia many
people in siena want to hold someone
responsible and make them pay even if
everyone knows that won't make the debt
burden disappear
you